we'll get to those stories in just a
moment but we begin with breaking news
the driver in a crash which killed a
metro police officer is charged nearly
one year later thank you for joining us
at four I'm Kirsten Joyce and I'm Brian
Loftus now it happened back in June of
2022 after a beam collapsed onto the
card detective Justin Terry was driving
a new investigator Vanessa Murphy
joining us now in studio Vanessa has
more truck driver Glenn Lewis is charged
with vehicular manslaughter the
allegation is that what he was driving
was too big for the roads and did not
comply with traffic rules as a result
investigators say he crashed which
resulted in a beam falling on detective
Justin Terry's car this was the scene in
June of 2022 Terry was pronounced dead
at the scene his family is suing Las
Vegas Paving which was doing the
construction on the 95 Western States
Contracting which owned the truck and
Glenn Lewis the driver it appears Lewis
may have had had several traffic
citations before in 2014 a Glenn Joseph
Lewis had to complete five hours of
traffic school for disobey being a
traffic controlled device and in 2015
there's a citation for driving a vehicle
exceeding the gross weight I called
Lewis and after I said I was a reporter
he hung up we are working to find out
whether there's any arrangement for him
to turn himself in a city spokesman
tells me his attorneys do have the court
filing by the way vehicular manslaughter
is a misdemeanor in Nevada if convicted
the punishment is up to six months in
jail back to you